[music]
nfl
in my life is able to choose and offer
new things even more even even
no more son mammalia gives you
the case
started bang bang and olufsen come home
rockets from boris i can do everything chuck
norris should throw out bukin he said
options
yuri konnov snare drum  and rice mageve
between
to his
gene
amati gate gear by logging in
territory to
drink up.  make a candle
and violating the village code moment and place
and behind the voice set out
n-no ass yes dozorme endo
picket was his son a
scarlet lock folder and be no books
are a good
why sochi we both mary jane e mail
forwarding
africa she will leave the show  in my
heart rid of all for the sake of the next
by the workers
like this country club
[music]
[applause]
he